you're alive
um good morning and welcome to this
meeting of the licensing subcommittee of
Malden District Council we're in the
council chamber today the
8th of December
um my name is councilor Maddie Thompson
I'm the chair of the committee on my
left I have councilor Jeanette stilts a
member of the subcommittee and on my
right we have councilor Michael Helm the
other member of the subcommittee
um do we have apologies Miss bird we are
missing a member but I don't know if
we've heard from them
I've got no apologies for tonight okay
just for clarity we are normally for but
we call it with three
um so that's why we're down to three and
usually four before we commence the
business of the meeting there's just a
few housekeeping rules to run through
we're streaming this meeting live the
beginning of it anyway as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded when invited to speak
everyone please turn on your microphones
speak clearly referencing a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
papers please keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking as this is important for the
streaming to be heard clearly finally
can I draw your attention to the notices
regarding the different levels within
the chamber and advise that the fire
exit is the door behind the top table
which is that one
right carrying on
um
sorry I have to dodge about here quite a
bit
right disclosure of interest
um to disclose the existence and nature
of any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members so this
only applies to the three of us members
are reminded that they're also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
to the meeting I have none Council
stilts none councilor help none thank
you
right item five is exclusion of the
public and press to resolve that under
Section 100a brackets for the Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph one of part one of
schedule 12a to the ACT and that this
satisfies the public interest test ISO
proposed do I have a second that second
did by Council stilts agreed agreed all
agreed so um thank you Miss bird if you
can stop the streaming and we'll carry
on with the private part of the session